hello nice to meet you hi
hi nice to meet you
uh so uh for uh first of all my name is
uh primekai i'm not sure if you you even
know that since someone just shared the
stream with you um my name is prime um
so nice to meet you uh could you
introduce yourself to my audience
yeah my name is pearl i run the channel
just pearly things on youtube
okay yes um we had i'm only familiar i
only just recently became familiar with
you because i discovered your channel on
june 4th i can tell you because i'm
looking at my youtube history um okay
uh we were uh looking through we were
doing just like reacting to youtube
videos uh we uh we're looking at people
within
uh the manusphere but specifically
females uh women
who kind of just uh exist in that space
and so we started with melanie king um
oh yeah yeah melanie king led us to a
real femme sapien and that quickly
yeah okay
yeah yeah um and so we were watching uh
your uh stuff you have a pretty
interesting thing i i would like to talk
to you about like a whole list of things
we have a really fun discussion um but i
know you have a very limited amount of
time you got your own thing uh that
you're gonna uh be up to so uh what did
you wanna talk about like yeah
yeah so i i don't know a ton about your
channel i was just upset this stream a
little bit ago someone on instagram and
i was like oh my gosh i have a twitch
now i can i can do twitch so it's my
first twitch
real stream anyways
um
but so my question was you're
she said you were talking about trans
women in sports yeah
um what is your position on that
i think that trans women should be
allowed in sports assuming uh they meet
certain um medical criteria in terms of
like human um
uh human replacement human yep
testosterone replacement all that good
stuff yeah
okay so like what what requirements
um i'd leave that up to
uh like people who know better than
myself right so
my understanding is that two years on
hrt uh
leaves them in a state uh that
makes them far more comparable um in
terms of uh
athletic ability to um
assist women
okay so do you think they're that they
have no advantage at all when they
transition is that your take
i'm gonna have no event no it's not my
talent not at all oh okay it's a no okay
so
why
so
what do you so you think they do have an
advantage or you don't know
i think it depends on the individual
right so i
would have more advantages uh than
others right i can fully believe that
maybe for some in a bit like maybe a
blanket rule wouldn't even work right
that it has to be evaluated um like
individually um that maybe have a
generalized uh uh benchmark but then uh
it's possible that a certain individual
doesn't meet that benchmark right and
maybe has to wait longer on hrt to yeah
so it would be different for different
individuals like you don't think it
could be a blanket
like it couldn't be two years i'm saying
i i
don't have enough knowledge to be
absolutely certain of like just two
years as a hard rule right two years is
the
latest i've heard um through you know um
uh uh through
news that's covered this right talk
about the specific situation um if there
is uh further science on that i'd be
listening uh willing to hear it however
my my contention is is that um
they might indeed have an advantage um
okay but i think it's odd that this
specific advantage
is something uh that
uh we care so much about there are so
many advantages in sports right like
people come uh with genetic advantages
people come uh with um advantages in
terms of either skill knowledge finance
is another thing right
yeah right um all those things set
people apart um on the level of training
all those things set people apart but
this on this specifically this one axis
right now we're banning people which i
think is really interesting
so you think that a financial advantage
is the same thing as a biological
advantage in terms of you think it's odd
people
care about one and not the other
i'm just trying to make sure i'm
understanding what you're saying correct
problem no problem yeah yeah yeah so i
don't think they're the same i think
they're different these things manifest
in different ways and they have
different uh consequences um but i think
that uh in terms of giving a person an
edge if that's the thing that we're
concerned about giving a person an edge
having access to like world-class
trainers right and then not having
access to that um will make a difference
right in your performance
right but like you could take someone
that's you know poor and give them
world-class trainers and they could be
in a completely different position so
like i played at um i played semi-pro
volleyball in europe right and i played
in college and i played in club in high
school and one thing in club what they
would do is they would sponsor
low-income kids and they would take them
like from their area like if they saw
someone that was athletic right they
would take them and give them the best
trainers and the best training where
like i can't physically become a guy
and cut like and have that advantage
like bone density wrist strength that
sort of thing
um and among athletes it's pretty
like i'll give you an example my brother
he's never lifted in his life i've been
lifting for 10 plus years i will never
be as strong upper body as my brother
because they're just built different
yeah okay so um and so so someone that's
like maybe low income they could
potentially you know get in they could
get money or like get in the right
opportunity and then
move up but i can't
make myself six seven
sure or make myself yeah god
but
exactly i mean you beat me to it right i
think you're already quite tall but like
you can't make yourself tall right right
and if uh being tall is an advantage in
your particular sport then like a person
who is taller than you has that inherent
advantage right even if they're cis
right their assist is a visual right but
like okay so we're gonna take height
right so i'm in the top one percent of
female athletes in terms of height
i i would be in the top 15 percent in
terms of men
so you would be essentially taking all
opportunity away from girls like me
because i i can't compete with the top
15 percent of men
because okay so i was i'm six foot right
and i was short for d1 schools i got
overlooked for a lot of division one
schools because they prefer girls that
are around six too if you're bringing
trans men into it like it's just not
fair
when you
not all and
on top of that what about bone density
and brits wrist strength
yeah so
and lung capacity
okay and and if and if it was equal why
don't why don't women go into men's
sports and start dominating there too
uh well it's not first of all my
contention isn't that it's equal um at
all okay so i'm saying that that's fine
i'm saying that there are individuals
who uh come into us more and dominate
nonetheless so um
uh the
easy example michael phelps right um if
you remember uh during the olympics for
the last olympics where he competed um
they did that super creepy [ __ ] thing
right where they examined all his body
right and gave you the whole breakdown
and like he has like webbed fingers and
all it was really weird i didn't like
that but still apparently he has a whole
bunch of mutations that add up and
happen to give them a series of
advantages um that uh cannot be over uh
well not overcome uh they can't um be
replicated by anyone else right it's
just born with it and he has that
advantage and there's no one ever in the
history of men that could replicate that
advantage
i mean ever the things that he was born
with you're talking about right like in
terms of uh like the like the web
fingers like you can't replicate his
genetic structure but still right the
point is that they allowed him to still
compete with other men right other men
who don't have those same advantages
like still that's that's just the the
sport right i either surpassed that
through training or you don't
so but my thing is another guy could be
born with that advantage too correct
it's what it's a possibility yeah yeah
but the thing is you can't you can't
have a girl that's gonna have the same
lung capacity bone density and wrist
strength as a dude it just doesn't
happen and again go back to my question
as why aren't women dominating in the
men's category
because what you're going to see is
you're going to see it's the end of
women's sports
because men are going to come in and
dominate and that's and that's the thing
because i think a lot of people that
aren't athletes don't understand that
like we train 12 15 years for this
that's why a lot of people care we spend
our whole lives training for the little
opportunity that there is in women's
sports and so for a couple moments that
we get and so in the case of leah thomas
like that was an opportunity taken away
from a biological woman
so okay and so
you go ahead go ahead
yeah yeah uh so um
i understand why athletes would care
right like good as yeah
and honestly sorry one more thing why
why does it matter who's who's using the
argument anyway like it's either it's
right or it's it correct or it's
incorrect who cares who's saying it
like what is what what does their
intentions matter it's either it's
correct or it's incorrect um no
intentions matter a lot actually right
like um there are people who um
uh like there are individuals who like
really care about uh gun violence uh
like uh or black and black crime in
chicago right
you know they care because they bring it
up all the time right well no they
actually bring it up when um uh they
have an instance of like uh a police
shooting uh a black man like a white
officer killing a black man right and
then they'll say why are we
concentrating on this what about the
black on black crime of chicago these
are people who don't actually give a
[ __ ] about that right um just use the
political tool so actually it does
matter what your intentions are because
sometimes you can't be disingenuous
right but how do you know what their
intentions are
you're never going to know what
someone's intentions are so why argue
about it hold on you can like
implicit um uh you can make a judgment
but your judgment could be different
than my judgment right so like going
back and forth about like what are their
intentions just seems like a bit of a
waste of time you know absolutely waste
the time um it's actually to know that
the person is a good faith of bad faith
and the arguments whether you should
even be wasting your time talking to
them no i think it actually does matter
we see that all the time on these
discussions we don't have to focus on
that but okay yeah yeah okay
uh so uh you talked about um um oh uh
men men coming into uh women's sports
one there isn't a flood of trans
individuals uh coming in trans uh women
coming into uh women's sports right this
is not like this great tidal wave but
right um uh like even
those who have so far yeah okay so far
even as yeah
exactly a national swimming title was
taken from a woman but okay yeah okay
and here's the thing and this is my
problem right the fact that it's the
fact that if there's any success from a
trans woman any success at all right
it must be it must be because of that
advantage that uh they have right so
have you seen have you seen pictures
have you seen pictures of them
you can't you don't think he was at any
advantage no okay so uh she right um but
uh
so
like
i think that uh people on your side of
the argument um
even if even if trans uh individuals
were like last place
uh yeah uh you'd be saying hey they're
taking a spot away from someone
like it doesn't matter like their
performance level like um if they uh
perform anything above um
like uh
if they are included in the competition
at all right it's taking away a spot
from apparently someone else
is buttercream yes
yes
yes
and i think that's pretty disgusting
especially again because there are other
women who have other advantages like uh
if a woman a cis woman is born with
elevated levels of testosterone she's
going to have an advantage right um but
you can still let her play correct
if she is elevated i don't know enough
about women that have elevated levels of
testosterone i'm just like
that's not something i've really looked
into that would be an advantage right
like if testosterone is an advantage
that people like talk uh right but okay
that's one out of many though bone
density risk strength lung capacity that
men have an advantage and a height that
men have an advantage over women yeah
yeah
height is variable right like uh
by and large though by and large men are
taller than women and if you look at the
extreme cases so if we're gonna go to
the extremes because that's when you
look at the top athletes performing like
it's gonna be the extremes right because
those are the best of the best in both
divisions
right
so so by and large by and large like the
wnba is going to be shorter than the nba
correct
um i i i guess yeah i'm sure
yeah and i hope you know like i like you
as a person you seem very nice this is
just i'm just trying to debate with you
but but i'm saying by and large men have
an advantage because that's why we say
it's going to be the end of women's
sports because if you start to see men
by and large that you could say i know
you would say like trans trans women but
like just for the sake of the argument
i'm going to say men okay just to be
clear of who we're talking about so men
that have transitioned into women by and
large um
like you're gonna see them
taking women's spots at the top division
and that's what you saw already with
leah thomas
except and
go ahead god go on sorry and the best a
majority of cases right in the back if
you look across um
all leagues and like all divisions um
and
the vast majority of women sports where
trans individuals are there
trans women aren't winning they aren't
making it to the podium
right
isn't that like if we look actually look
at reality and we look at the
individuals who are on top of polos you
have leo thomas right and you have that
uh hubbard individual um right to the
weightlifting thing right but i think
one is too many one is too many because
you don't understand like as
a as as yeah one is too many because
when you think about it those girls have
trained for 12 years 12 plus year we
spent our whole life training for the
little opera so so we've spent all whole
lives training for the little
opportunity that we have in women's
sports
and now we're competing against people
that have a biological advantage over us
everyone has a biological advantage
everyone everyone has a bio someone has
about so if you have a biological
advantage over someone else a system
talk and we eliminate all the trans
women right okay if we do then why then
why aren't women then why aren't women
competing within men's sports
no because you've agreed that it's not
equal so if they have an advantage why
are you letting them compete
if they have
i don't like so so like lung capacity
yeah yeah yeah so like lung capacity
so
according to the science that i've seen
that um uh them going on hrt them going
through the transitionary process like
uh evens the playing ground into a to a
uh discrepancy um that is fair you can't
eliminate discrepancy because how would
you do that like how would you like who
would you match them up with right you
can't like
dude that's not a thing that can
actually happen right um but you uh
lower uh the discrepancy there to i
think an acceptable degree um and again
there's discrepancies like if you take
treatment out of the conversation
between everyone who comes into a sport
right um i'm sure you'd have an
advantage for me if i played [ __ ]
volleyball i think i'm sure you'd crush
me um because you have certain
advantages there right including the
skill including the training um and all
the other things and that's okay
but see it's it's not the same though
because here here's the thing like i
played basketball also for 12 years like
i played in college i did basketball
volleyball i ran track right and the
thing is even with all the basketball
training that i've had i know if i go
against a dude he even with the same
training in the same skill level he
beats me every single time
uh in this same and and
is that the case no we've seen yes no no
no men
and
okay then why did the then the 16 year
old soccer team beat the international
women's team the men's 16 teams team
beat the international the best the best
women's team in the country i
i haven't heard that that sounds [ __ ]
absolutely no that's absolutely true
i'll take your word for it i'm not
saying you're lying uh but i just i
haven't heard of that yeah they kicked
us
uh to uh it's gonna make a difference
uh to commentate on that because i just
don't know yeah
and the other thing is like you're not
the one that's directly experiencing the
results
so
so like it's easy for you to say oh
compete against them right but when when
i when i go up against dudes we get our
ass handed to us
and it's just
it's like easy to say that from the
outside looking in when you're not the
one that's going up against them
okay so one i don't think you're going
up against man i think you're going up
against a trans woman a trans woman who
has met some sort of medical standard
uh for uh entering the competition right
some sort of equitable standard um so uh
and that would mean um uh them were
losing um
some of that advantage and uh being
within a discrepancy
some of that advantage but not but not
lung capacity rick's wrist and wrist
strength you have more of that you know
so you have more lung capacity than some
other women right correct
nah i have asthma
okay we'll only use one capacity but
fair enough
um but um
fair enough um i'm sorry i hear that um
but uh yeah i'll make it i still i still
kill it
um bone density or uh whatever it is
right there you have an advantage over
another woman in your sport a cis woman
in your sport correct
do i have an advantage over and it
depends on the woman yeah exactly yeah
yeah
but by and large an average guy an
average guy has more lung capacity and
wrist strength than the average woman so
by and large yeah
so by and large they're going to you're
going to see women losing titles
which isn't fair why don't women have
the right to their own division why
don't we leah leah thomas just did it
so that's and that's the first
yes we have and that's
and that's a very small percentage of
the population that's a very small
percentage you're already seeing the
titles if they're going actually if
there is actually um why don't women
have the right to their own division
they do we have one and we're including
more women
why don't biological women have the
right to our own division
um
why do men always need to invade women's
spaces
that's that's lovely uh well uh i i am
certainly not advocating for men to
invade women's spaces i only want women
there right and so uh we're just
including our trans uh sisters into
those spaces uh so once again uh trans
individuals have uh met a certain
medical standard um uh
those are the individuals um
i think that
um
[Music]
if
if we saw
a
uh we had a situation in which trans
women were consistently uh on the podium
right um across these sports and they
were consistently on the podium and they
were locking uh
uh cis women out i think you'd have a
much better argument and think i'd be on
your side well like it seems like there
is some insurmountable um uh-huh so
let's just wait till that let's just
wait till that happens
yeah actually yeah because i i'm not
convinced yet that there actually is a
problem you still have yet to convince
me of that like if we look at actual
reality right there are very few
individuals can we pull up a picture can
we pull up a picture of leah thomas
versus the second place you cannot tell
me in your right mind everyone
uh uh everyone uh
as [ __ ] i forget what i was gonna say um
um
everyone has uh some sort of advantage
god that wasn't what i was gonna say
sorry i forgot my point there um
what was the last thing you said
it's okay uh we'll just continue on um
uh
so
oh yeah looking at reality as it stands
right you would expect um that with the
amount of trans people and there are a
significant amount of trans individuals
who are in these sports um that we would
already see this that we all already see
um the field tilting um but we don't
right we have uh um an exception right
leah thomas and like there's like a
handful of how many how many trans
people are in the sports
you said it's not a significant amount
so how many
uh oh i said not
i said it's not an insignificant amount
okay i was just curious if you knew how
many i i don't know exactly how many i
know that okay um and some states where
they pass these laws believe it wasn't
ohio if i'm getting that wrong please
excuse me um but in ohio they pass a
a ban on trans uh women in sports or
trans uh girls in sports and there's
only one of them right one of them
what percent what percentage of the
population is trans i'm just curious
what percent of the population is trans
less than one percent so you have less
than one percent of the population and
you already see a title being taken by
less than one percent of the population
we have we have one title
oh no it's okay okay i know i understand
the sarcasm because it's not a big deal
for you but when you've trained 20 15
years no no when you've trained 15 years
your whole life for an opportunity just
have it taken away by a guy that has a
biological advantage over you like it's
it's not oh no when when you're the
person that's in second place sure sure
the sanctuary won't spawn it doesn't
mean anything to me right so like uh it
actually does mean something to me
because of discrimination um that my
trans brothers and sisters are facing
that's why it means something to me
right um i know i'm not an athlete like
you i know i haven't trained that's fair
right but um when i see discrimination
that's a problem for me always it
doesn't matter if i'm not involved how
is it discrimination when it's a law
like it's biological men biological
women
like how is that discrimination or not a
law but like if the rules is biological
men that's one division biological women
is one division
um okay how's the discrimination when
there's a rule uh white's in one league
and black's another league
that's a good argument actually yeah
yeah that's a good one that's a good one
um
yeah fair enough but do you think that
all the all the divisions should be like
together then no matter what there
shouldn't be any separation
so do
because then like by that logic then
like all men should be able it should
just be one division
yeah so uh
i think that
well
i don't know i am not a uh a sports
expert i still stimulate that keep that
in mind i don't know however
um however
i would imagine uh that there might
possibly be a sport where uh men and
women can uh compete uh on an even
ground right yeah maybe [ __ ] like
curling all right that seems uh
something that she could probably do um
but they're looking at the rest of the
strengths
um but okay but uh if if there was a
sport in which uh the advantages weren't
um so stark right then i think you could
right um but right um uh i i think that
but if there's always but if there's but
if there's always advantages and
advantages don't matter then why don't
you just make one division
no i'm saying again because you're
saying you were saying earlier that like
like there's always going to be
advantages right so then why have a
division at all why have a woman in a
men's division why not just have one
sure right but what i also said is that
when trans women go through their um uh
their transformation um they
uh and like i don't know hrt for a
certain amount of time uh they lose some
of that advantage right it's not that
there will be no advantage right because
that's not a thing
like that thought really doesn't even
make sense when it comes to sports right
like it it doesn't register to have no
advantage um right but uh like you can
lower right lower that delta right that
difference um right point where it it
can be within an acceptable range and
i'll leave that up to um individuals who
have more knowledge medical knowledge to
figure out what that level should be
yeah because what i just don't
understand is because your argument is
that if there's always going to be
advantages like they should be allowed
in so then why not have one division
why not just have one did you
because of the things that i just said
pearl i i
that was my answer just now
oh i just did i didn't think it was that
good one no offense okay fair enough oh
that's fine that's fine but like that
was my answer like because you're saying
that it lowers the advantages but it's
still they're still at an advantage
yes and you still have an advantage um
over someone else right uh right so
let's just get rid of the divisions
let's get rid of it i have a division at
all
for the things that i just said so
there's no reason for me to repeat those
things uh so like i don't know whatever
the things that you're
but like that that's my
answer there i can just repeat this
again
yeah go ahead you can repeat it again
because the difference
is you feel like minuscule you feel like
it's minuscule i no no i would i
well i don't know if i would
characterize his minuscule i don't know
i would say i would characterize it um
as something that can be overcome i
guess because you look you can you can
admit okay right amongst us
at what point is it small enough
yeah
um that there there's going to be
someone who comes to a sport that has a
complete genetic advantage but that
person is not unbeatable right um
that i think lebron james would be
pretty unbeatable he'd be pretty
unbeatable lebron james right among
cis-men right is not unbeatable correct
right like he might have a genetic
advantage over i don't know if this is
true but uh let's pretend he does over
never put him on
for two years and put him in the women's
division no no uh he had again so engage
with the question please okay so yeah
99
of the uh uh cis uh men uh in the nba
right but even then like it's possible a
person who trains hard enough right um
and works hard enough to um to beat him
correct lebron james isn't unbeatable in
basketball
is he on i don't know he's pretty good
i'd say the greatest of all time
buy some he someone could probably beat
him yeah okay great some some some man
could probably beat him michael jordan
and his man
yeah exactly exactly no i yeah i hear
you right yeah but michael jordan in his
day was beaten right like there's a
whole list of athletes who at the top of
their game yes who are yes all right and
being serious not by a woman
not by a woman indeed indeed right but
also um like uh since we understand that
they are these advantages and these
matches come from lots of different ways
lebron james had the time technology
uh lebron
indeed
like biology but also yeah financial
resources having the time to train
having access to coaches um having
access to nutrition all these things add
up yeah um
and our advantages but we don't
discriminate based on any of those
things uh-huh so i have a question do
you think michael jordan or actually
let's use lebron james he could go on
testosterone for two years and then
compete in the women's division
i'm sorry i'm sorry um not testosterone
uh whatever hormone blockage yeah
estrogen my bad my bad so if they go on
estrogen for two years
you think that's fair
would that be fair like i said yeah
obviously it's a possibility for someone
you wouldn't be close enough sorry close
enough close enough yeah because you
didn't stay fair specifically it just
has to be at a certain point like close
enough sure right yeah okay sure uh
maybe maybe that's true i don't know
yeah like i'm saying but i said but i
said at the very start of this right um
that it might be the case that a blanket
rule isn't good enough right so the case
that uh for lebron james that uh two
years isn't enough maybe he might be an
athletic man only it'll be like if you
can lift too much no
well maybe
when only
well i don't i don't know but i'm saying
or or hear me out it could just be
biological woman biological nut
like that seems a little more simple or
we could just not like discriminate
right uh because
they have a league they can go in the
men's division we can make a trans
division
we could do a division filled with
nobody wonderful right
that's great
a separate equal division filled with
nobody fair enough right uh if we can
gather five uh trans people one day
right then yeah i guess we'll have a
tournament for you great
so i'm sorry
um yeah we could i could make it lit i'm
a real good events planner let me tell
you i do recruiting for the show yeah i
could find it i'm sure trans women never
will be hitting you up for your services
any time now um
you sure you sure
i'm sorry
but yeah so i i just uh have a
deep disagreement there do you have any
other points on this particular actually
i have to go because i have a stream in
12 minutes now
but this was fun i enjoyed it um
if you want me back if you want me back
i'll come back i just sent you a friend
request when i discovered okay okay
you're my first discord friend awesome
um but yeah i would love to have you a
back especially on your takes on the
manosphere that's why we uh came to like
um we originally discovered you because
of your uh takes there i think that'd be
super hard people are reacting to me on
discord i didn't even know i had like i
had no idea you reacted to me
uh but you better have said nice things
i i said things um but anyway don't you
come back don't make me come back and
call you out oh please do i would love
it but uh curly thank you so much good
luck with your stream um yeah we'd love
to talk to you again in the future
okay cool have a good one
bye